your skull femur and rib cage are now
gone along with the rest of your
skeleton
welcome to your body without bones
this essential part of your Anatomy is
suddenly gone poof
what happens now
how would losing your bones make you
incredibly sick
why would you lose all your teeth
and how long would you last as a
boneless blob
this is what if and here's what would
happen if you had no bones
okay so why are your bones so important
well your skeletal system is made up of
tendons ligaments and cartilage and it's
not just a sturdy structure that keeps
you standing straight
your bones produce blood cells fats and
minerals that support your entire body
but now we're gonna take all these
essential bones out of you from your
skull to the phalanges of your toes
[Music]
for debt keeping your feet on the ground
you're now a human jellyfish and you
won't last very long
you don't have to become a shapeless
blob to know that life can sometimes
feel unstable let's be real mental
health challenges can seriously distress
you and prevent you from achieving your
goals it could be anxiety or depression
or maybe you're just a human going
through a hard time but just as your
skeletal system provides you with
structure and support well therapy can
equip you with the tools to navigate
these challenges that's why I'm thrilled
to tell you about the sponsor of this
episode better help their mission is to
make the often daunting world of therapy
more accessible and affordable finding
the right therapist can feel tricky
especially when you're restricted to the
options in your local area well better
help is here to change that it breaks
down geographical barriers and matches
you with a professional therapist based
on your specific needs all within a few
days and signing up is easy just click
on the link in the description below or
go to betterhelp.com
for 10 off your first month of Better
Health another thing I really like about
betterhelp is that you don't have to be
stuck with the therapist that you don't
fit with you can easily swap your
therapist for free and get the best help
possible see getting help doesn't have
to be stressful you're just a few clicks
away most people spend hours in the gym
or on the treadmill every week so why
not give your mind the same kind of
attention if you're struggling consider
online therapy with Better Health click
on the link in the description or go to
betterhelp.com
and thanks again better help for
supporting this channel
so what exactly would your boneless life
be like
well for starters you wouldn't be able
to move now you can just watch what if
videos in bed all day guilt free
and don't panic just take a deep breath
but not too deep because you don't have
a rib cage and without a rib cage your
lungs won't be able to expand
not having bones means you'd need to be
hooked up to a ventilator 24 7. and now
you're way more susceptible to
infections because your Airways are
always open
this would let all sorts of nasty germs
in a common cold could quickly become
pneumonia
but pneumonia would be the least of your
worries
that's because without your bones you
don't have any bone marrow yeah okay so
why is this such a big deal well because
your bone marrow is the main part of the
body that produces your white and red
blood cells and without new blood cells
your immune system will be weaker you'll
be susceptible to diseases like leukemia
but at least you could try to enjoy a
nice meal without any bones right oh
wait no scratch that you wouldn't have
any teeth
your teeth aren't bones but they're
anchored in your Jawbone and without a
Jawbone nothing would be holding your
teeth in place you wouldn't be able to
chew and you'd need to be fed through a
feeding tube
yeah so there aren't many positives when
it comes to a life without bones sure
you could avoid bone related diseases
and you wouldn't have to worry about
breaking any of your bones again but
that's about it
the worst part is you wouldn't last very
long
without the structure and support that
bones give to your body and with no bone
marrow to produce blood cells your
survival would be measured in minutes to
a few hours
okay okay what if instead of instantly
removing our bones we just evolved
without them
yeah well if we evolved without bones we
would have never made it out of the
ocean
we'd be living our lives like human
jellyfish or we might have evolved to
have an exoskeleton like the Clown
that sounds gross I know but the good
news is that you wouldn't have to deal
with it for very long
your lifespan would decrease
significantly since the skeleton
provides much needed protection for your
organs
yeah your squishy brain would be left
without its hard helmet leaving your
Noggin extremely vulnerable and not to
mention your heart lungs and liver would
also be in danger without your rib cage
yeah okay this was a bad idea
our bones do way more than we give them
credit for and we shouldn't take them
for granted did you know that some
people have a rare genetic disease
similar to having no bones
it's called hypophosphatasia and it
affects one in one hundred thousand
babies born
people with this condition have bones
that have difficulty absorbing calcium
and phosphorus making them extremely
weak and prone to breaking
thankfully doctors are working on unique
enzyme treatments these allow the bones
to slowly grow back so patients can move
again
our bones are essential sure they can
break and they might get in the way of
things but without them we wouldn't be
able to live
okay so now instead of having no bones
what if your stomach acid suddenly
disappears
well that sounds like a story for
another
what if
[Music]
foreign